[Music]
on this friday night
canada's economy on a roller coaster
ride
covet 19 infects the country's finances
to a record low
and the signs a quick recovery is on the
way the new conservative leader on the
possibility of an election
the liberals are rattling the sword and
they're playing some games our global
news exclusive with aaron o'toole
strict rules take flight the
consequences for violators of westjet's
new face masks policy
and sewage brewage this was exciting for
us the canadian company crafting up
sustainable beer
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
the economic impact of the pandemic has
hit a staggering
benchmark canada's economy suffered its
biggest drop on record
the gross domestic product shrank 38.7
percent in the second quarter
as the economy slowed to a crawl
millions of canadians were laid off
during the widespread lockdown
and more than eight million people
turned to the federal government for
financial support
so is the worst behind us our chief
political correspondent david aiken
joins us with more on the record drop
and the promising new signs of a rapid
recovery david
well rob in canada's economy was also
the worst
in the world for that period april
through june and
that's because the federal and
provincial governments
shut down businesses and schools and
kept them shut down through most of the
quarter
in order to prevent the spread of
covenanting
canada's economy is built on three
pillars
consumer spending business spending and
international trade
and in the second quarter all three of
those pillars
took a pounding like never before
household spending plunged 13
with shops and restaurants shut down
consumers did not have many places to
spend their money
business investment dropped 16.2 percent
stats can chalk that up to limited
construction activity
plant closures low oil prices and
overall
uncertainty exports sank by eighteen
point
four percent while imports sag by twenty
three percent
blame that on plant shutdowns and a
border closed to tourists
but there was a glimmer of good data
that could help spur
a rapid record-setting recovery the
amount of
disposable income consumers had actually
rose
10.8 percent in the quarter that's a
result of
massive government support programs like
the serb that appears to have
offset job losses but that came with a
cost
the federal government said friday that
the deficit skyrocketed in the quarter
to 120 billion dollars
versus just 85 million dollars for the
same period last year
in any event that means there's a lot of
pent up consumer buying power
ready to help rapidly reinflate the
economy
and indeed that is just what is
happening canada's gdp
is on a pace already to set a record for
a
jump in gdp in the current quarter and
this time
canada's economy is outperforming the
united states
and most of its peers and that's because
canada is doing a better
job than most others in keeping coven 19
under control robin david aiken in
ottawa thanks david
a copa 19 vaccine development deal
between canada and china
has been scrapped the national research
council of canada says the cannes sino
biologics vaccine has not been approved
by chinese customs
for shipment to canada clinical trials
were supposed to be done at halifax's
dalhousie university
the government says it's now focusing on
other partners and potential
covet 19 vaccines we have to keep
re-evaluating that situation and
you know we may be looking at more than
one vaccine so i think
that i guess the bottom line to your
question is yes we
we have sort of keeping all of those
options
open and we'll continue to do so
canada china relations have been
strained since beijing detained
canadians michael koverig and michael
spavor in apparent retaliation
for the 2018 arrest of huawei executive
mong wang zhou
in vancouver newly minted conservative
leader erin o'toole has a potential
election to plan
for just days into the gig he sat down
today with our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stephenson for his first
one-on-one interview since his victory
mercedes
we're here with the west block in
downtown toronto to meet with the brand
new conservative leader aaron o'toole
he's only been in the job for a week but
he already is working on winning over
voters from areas like this
the 416 downtown toronto and the greater
toronto area
as he approached for our interview it
was interesting to see he was stopped by
a significant number of people
who knew who he was and wanted to say
something a lot of those canadians
wondering if there will be an election
and we wondered what he's going to do to
win over voters who the conservatives
couldn't convince to come on board in
the last election
this is what he said it's time for a lot
of canadians to take another look at the
conservative party including many voters
in the gta
here in the 416 more women more new
canadians
we actually have a very diverse talented
and passionate caucus we're going to be
growing that
and we want to fight for the interests
of canadians particularly after the
pandemic
small businesses startups here in
toronto are having trouble and
they're going to see a conservative
party really putting forward a plan for
the future with a new generation of
leadership
who is focused on the well-being of the
country and not images and selfies as
we've seen with mr trudeau
while mr o'toole says that the
conservatives are ready for an election
it's clear that he's not spoiling for
one he would not commit
to bringing the government down or
trying to saying that he has greater
priorities at this time
among those priorities helping to look
after canadians during the pandemic
and while the opposition has been very
critical of the liberals approach
we asked them what they would do
differently to help canadians through a
second wave of covet 19
and to get the canadian economy back on
track we're going to have their back
because we want them to have a job
in fact the liberals have no plan after
the serb we were putting out plans
for emergency assistance in the ei in
february
long before the government even acted to
to to reduce the risks from the
coronavirus
so we're going to make sure the economy
is growing again that capital comes to
canada
that there's jobs and investment and
you're going to see a series of policies
rolled out
that i'm very excited about because i i
was in the private sector here in
toronto for 10 years
before after my military time but before
politics
as i said i'm not a celebrity i'm here
to fight for canadian interests and
canadian families
we'll have more of that exclusive
interview with aaron o'toole on how
he'll manage party unity
introducing himself to canadians and the
tone in politics nowadays that'll air on
sunday morning
for the west block i'm mercedes
stevenson in toronto
in the u.s more details are emerging
about the police shooting of jacob blake
the department of justice says two
officers deployed tasers in failed
attempts to stop blake on sunday
officer ruston chesky then shot him in
the back multiple times as blake opened
his car door
chesky is the only officer who deployed
a firearm
all three officers have been put on
administrative leave
blake is now paralyzed from the waist
down he was initially handcuffed
to his hospital bed every black person
in the united states is going to stand
up
we're tired that is jacob blake's father
speaking to tens of thousands today at
the march on washington
it was on this day in 1963 that dr
martin luther king delivered his
celebrated
i have a dream speech today his son
followed in his footsteps and urged
everyone to make a difference
by voting the strength must be exercised
by more than reddick
and more than marching the simple
challenge before us
is that everyone can cast a ballot and
everyone who can must cast a ballot
and that ballot that is cast must be
counted
that november vote has america divided
more than ever
president donald trump accepted his
party's nomination last night at the
republican convention
but ignored the growing calls for change
and focused on claims that electing joe
biden
would bring lawlessness to america
tonight jackson proskal looks at how the
campaign between two very different
candidates
could play out a night of defiance from
the white house lawn
the fact is we're here and they're not
as donald trump accepted his party's
nomination
hundreds gathered outside the fence to
protest his presidency
a preview of a coming campaign that will
look like no
other before it amidst a raging pandemic
an economic collapse
and a nation on the march over systemic
racism these things are
things are touching people on a daily
basis
and so for that reason i think it's
really different because it really hits
home
with everybody in the united states not
just a few people who might be adversely
affected
donald trump and joe biden agree on only
one thing
that the very future of the country is
at stake this is a life-changing
election
this will determine what america is
going to look like for a long long time
and this election will decide whether we
will defend the american way of life or
whether we will allow a
radical movement to completely dismantle
and destroy it it's trump who finds
himself in a bind
down in the polls and left to argue that
america under joe biden
would suffer from the ills that arrived
under trump's presidency
no one will be safe in biden's america
biden faces the challenge of being a
traditional democrat
at perhaps the most untraditional time
in american history
this campaign isn't just about winning
votes it's about winning the heart and
yes the soul of america
a stark choice for voters when so few
remain
undecided both campaigns know that they
have a strong base
that really wants nothing else than to
defeat the other guy
the election may come down to who shows
up at the polls
driving both men to strike fear into the
hearts of their supporters
that if the vote doesn't go their way
the country might never recover
jackson proskow global news washington
the nba will resume its playoff schedule
tomorrow after agreeing to commitments
that made players comfortable continuing
play stopped wednesday in frustration
with the police shooting of blake in
wisconsin
the players and the league will
establish a social justice coalition
focusing on
issues such as criminal justice reform
and voting access
voter suppression which often includes
the elimination of polling stations
has disproportionately affected black
and other minority voters
a move by some of america's biggest
sports teams will help with that
while also enabling safer voting during
the pandemic
several teams are turning their stadiums
into polling stations for the november
election
at least 12 teams from the world of
basketball baseball football and hockey
announced the move to allow fast safe
and socially distanced voting
the la clippers golden state warriors
new jersey devils and pittsburgh
penguins are all part
of the push the remnants of hurricane
laura are hitting the southern u.s
tonight with heavy rain and powerful
winds
hundreds of thousands of people across
louisiana are still without power or
water after the storm made landfall
yesterday morning
in hard hit lake charles the city's
mayor says some residents could be
without basic services
for weeks at least six people were
killed in the storm mostly from falling
trees
laura is one of the most powerful
hurricanes to hit the u.s
forecasters say it could strengthen to a
tropical storm
again this weekend
in australia three people died when a
wild wind storm tore down trees in that
country's second largest city
two drivers died when their cars were
crushed and a four-year-old boy was
killed
after being struck by a falling tree
winds reached 158 kilometers an hour in
melbourne
the storm knocked out power to 56 000
homes
a massive cleanup is underway
a canadian airline unveils a new policy
coming up what could happen to
passengers
who don't wear a face mask plus jobs
fizzling out how much coca-cola is
cutting
its workforce
the westjet group has announced a strict
new policy to help ensure passengers
wear masks on its flights
starting september first anyone over the
age of two who refuses to wear a mask
could be denied boarding and banned from
flying with westjet for up to one year
and while on board anyone who isn't
wearing one will be asked to put one on
if that doesn't work then they'll be
given a warning if they still don't
comply
passengers will be placed on a no-fly
list travelers will also have to put in
contact information at check-in
to help with contact tracing in case
anyone with kova 19
boards a flight so far there have been
no reports in canada of transmission
during a flight the pandemic is behind
major job cuts at coca-cola
the world's largest beverage company is
slashing 4 thousand jobs in
canada the us and puerto rico coca-cola
says it will involve a mix of voluntary
buyouts and
involuntary cuts the company is also
streamlining its drink portfolio to
focus on more popular drinks
in the second quarter alone sales
dropped 28 percent
due to the closure of venues like
stadiums and movie theaters
two tick tock celebrities are facing
criminal charges for allegedly hosting
pandemic parties bryce hall and blake
gray are accused of holding two parties
earlier this month
despite la's ban on large gatherings the
social media stars share a home in the
hollywood hills
the city says it's not aware of any
kovid 19 cases
linked to the parties still ahead a tale
of two toms the hollywood actor strikes
the right key with a canadian
typewriter collector now to the sudden
resignation of japan's longest-serving
prime minister
in an address to the nation shinzo abe
says he's stepping down for health
reasons
abe suffers from an inflammatory bowel
disease called
ulcerative colitis he says the illness
has gotten worse recently
and that he doesn't want his condition
getting in the way of decision-making
the 65-year-old was first elected as
prime minister in 2012
and today apologized for failing to
complete his term
in office atm style drug dispensers are
being installed in five locations across
canada to help address the opioid crisis
the machines provide safe doctor
prescribed medication to users
by scanning their palm the technology is
an extension of a pilot project that
began
in the center of the epidemic
vancouver's downtown east side
jessie thomas reports it was during a
panel talk in 2017 when the idea came to
dr mark tyndall he was speaking about
ways to tackle the overdose crisis
when it occurred to him why not provide
a safe supply of drugs
and vending machines the media picked up
on it fast
after maybe 20 interviews of
backtracking i
came to the conclusion that that was the
best idea i ever had
nearly 6 000 kilometers away in
dartmouth nova scotia cory yantha
had already been working on a prototype
dispensing machine designed to
distribute cannabis
he reached out to tyndall to see about
collaborating you know i'm not sure if
you thought about the technology
but we have a solution here that can
distribute these products to
registered users in a secure low barrier
way
last december the first my safe verified
identity dispenser was set up in
vancouver's downtown east side as part
of a safe drug supply pilot project
it looks like an atm but it's filled
with a prescription opioid called
hydromorphone
it scans users hands to access their
pills
we've dispensed over four thousand
packets of schedule and narcotics
among the 20 people enrolled in the
initial project tyndall says there were
no overdoses it's a promising result at
a time when leaders are searching for
solutions
between january 2016 and december 2019
more than 15 000 people died of apparent
opioid overdoses
and the crisis is escalating this past
may british columbia reported 174
suspected opioid overdose deaths
a record high that record was broken a
month later with 177 deaths
in july another 175 people died
tyndall says current opioid drug
strategies are failing and more must be
done
to provide users with a safe supply if
we're watching people
buying poison and just standing around
with naloxone kits trying to revive them
i mean
how many years do you want to do that
earlier this summer the company behind
the drug dispensing machines received a
five hundred thousand dollar loan from
atlantic canada opportunities agency to
expand
three more dispensers are being set up
in bc machines are also headed to london
ontario
and the location right here in dartmouth
nova scotia this project is needed in
a number of communities across canada
and we're looking at expanding this
further
the hope is that by making safe drugs
available these machines can help get
the crisis under control
jesse thomas global news dartmouth nova
scotia
if you're old school and still have a
typewriter you'll like this next story
one of canada's last remaining
typewriter technicians received a
special
thanks from tom hanks the hollywood
actor replied to a letter from
saskatoon's tom
tolowski who first wrote to hanks to
thank the movie star for being the
celebrity face
for typewriter collectors which he
believes has helped spark
interest and bring back business on
facebook chilowski said he's honored
and speechless up next the secret
ingredient in alberta's
new beer
scientists in india have detected
ultraviolet light from what is believed
to be one of the earliest galaxies in
the universe
the light was seen using astrosat
india's first
multi-wavelength satellite the findings
published by the journal nature
astronomy
could help explain the origin of light
after the big bang
brewers in calgary have discovered a
greener way to make beer but
one ingredient will get your attention
besides the hops and barley
mix in calgary's waste water the treated
brew meets the bar
set by alberta's health authorities but
as heather urex west explains it may
take some convincing to get people
sipping these suds okay
it's not the most appetizing of thoughts
to think that water that began here in
your shower or
toilet could end up in something you
might drink
but a calgary brewery insists their new
waste water beer is pretty good
a natural golden ale 4.5 alcohol and
it's a golden bubbly
craft beer the small batch craft brew
was born from a partnership with the
university of calgary
and xylem water solutions the goal here
is to show
that with proper treatment recycled
water can be put
to all kinds of new uses landlocked
countries globally
are already having to look at at water
reuse
you know just to irrigate and and
have water in their homes as you know
climate change progresses and there's
less glaciers melting into the rivers
waters is going to become a bigger
bigger deal
a third of the world's population is
currently living in areas where fresh
water resources are under stress a
number that is expected to double within
five years in singapore recycled water
is already being used routinely
treated wastewater currently meets more
than 30 percent of the country's water
needs
this was exciting for us just because of
the sustainability piece i mean the
beverage industry obviously uses a lot
of water so
any way we can kind of reuse and give
back is obviously exciting to us
of course tainted water can be very
dangerous any kind of contamination has
the potential to make people very sick
that's why the water used for these
brews was treated carefully
using processes guided by public health
the water
as i said went through some different
treatment technologies nano filtration
advanced oxidation then through
reverse osmosis the result
a waste water beer that has been so well
received
a week after its launch it's almost sold
out
heather urex west global news calgary
a drink to think about and that is
global national for this friday i'm
robin gill
tonight your canada is fork lake in
northern alberta
we would love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching jeff semple will
be here tomorrow and i'll see you back
here on monday
have a great weekend
[Music]
you